christian souvient père de cédric
souvient des cd donc on le disait le 5
janvier dernier d'une asphyxie deux
jours après son interpellation sur le
quai branly dans le 7e arrondissement de
la capitale bonsoir pressant de vida
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france on imagine que
cette affaire giorgio floyd à a ravivé
chez vous de douloureux souvenirs les
similitudes sont bien là selon vous oui
yahia vos côtés des études il est mort
il est mort par asphyxie
cédric mans par un suicide donc c'est la
même morts ils ont été tous les deux
comme ba a condamné condamné à mort
après un contrôle de police
la peine de mort est abolie en france et
aujourd'hui les gardiens de la paix se
donne le droit de le donner la peine de
mort justement christophe aka salaires a
notamment annoncé la fin de cette
technique un de l'étranglement
c'est une vraie victoire c'est ce que
vous attendez depuis longtemps non c'est
pas une vraie victoire chez un tout
petit filet parce que le plaquage
centrale est aussi dangereux quand vous
avez deux trois gars sur votre dos tu
passeras le top 20 des ça peut faire
deux à trois cents kilos vous avez ça
sur le dos vous avez le ventre meurtri
j'avais tout cas toute la chaîne de
commandeur respiratoires kéké
complètement bloquée donc aujourd'hui on
peut pas dire que c'est une victoire
voilà bien un paquet est fait mais c'est
un effet d'annoncé tout tout ce qui a
été promis
il ya cinq fois qu'on l'a demandé on n'a
pas reçu un seul courrier on a paru chez
les avocats a pas été mis en rapport
c'est nous qui avons bien karoumi les
gens là bas aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
justement aux états unis qui semblent
aussi créé une vraie prise de conscience
une vraie colère en france avec ses
manifestations
c'est un vrai espoir dans votre combat
se font bien la preuve je sais que
aujourd'hui ça a réveillé les grandes
instances notre président s'est
manifestée parce qu'on n'avait rien fait
jusqu'à présent et ce week-end
lula faire de charge comment aux états
unis il a compris qu'il a compris qu'il
y avait un vrai problème
il fallait faire quelque chose et d'ascq
où on sort du chapeau
on va arrêter le lac et des tremblements
ça sera déjà une bonne chose ça va les
calmer
la famille se souvient n'est pas calmé
la famille traoré n'est pas cad comme
ahmad akkari n'est pas calmé on nous
errons lui donne des miettes donc on
voit qu'on voit là moi je suis pas
d'accord avec tout ce qui a été dit j'ai
croisé de ce castaner ce matin je lui ai
dit en face entre quatre yeux ce que je
pensais et il m'a même dit vous ne m'en
voulez un petit peu au jour en ce moment
vous avez un petit peu après moi je dis
jamais pas appel aux jeunes à nice
voilà la différence pourtant ce ministre
et sion se souvient on comprend
évidemment votre émotion à votre colère
mais c'est plutôt rare qu'un ministre de
l'intérieur voilà on connaisse un
problème de racisme au sein de de la
police
il y en a même qui accuse ans ce
ministre notamment au rassemblement
national de lâcher ses troupes
c'est quand même un début pour vous même
s'il n'est pas suffisant si oui alors si
simple plaisir à tout le monde sa dette
mais c'est qu'un début mais pour moi
c'est un feu de paille célibat il se
passe rien derrière
on a demandé comment qui des ide vers
des préparations faire des études
aujourd'hui on vous contrôle pour un
contrôle d'identité pour une infraction
au code de la route si elle en actions
ce qui est pas un cas en plus puisque
landes en train de le démontrer car eu
infraction
on ya mis un pv il a donné ses papiers
il a été arrêté il a été en règle
et là d'un seul coup la salle on vous
dit baye des morts il est pas mal 5
janvier va là il est mort le 3 janvier
sur le pavé au pied de la tour eiffel
ça c'est une réalité il est rentré on
l'a mis dans le samu il était
cliniquement mort ont l'art qu'on paie
pour être à faire démarrer son coeur qui
lui pour qu'il soit disant les moeurs de
joie après mais c'était déjà fini
aujourd'hui clairement qu est-ce que
vous aurez oui pardonnez mon passeront
la liaison a été coupée quelques
instants aujourd'hui clairement qu'est
ce que vous attendez de la justice vous
avez souvent dit que voilà
on voulait pas la profession entière
mais mais à ces quatre individus qui ont
interpellé
votre fils qu'est ce que vous attendez
renard tous les tueurs d'enfants
les tueurs de pair les tueurs de comment
de mari j'en veux à tous ces gens là qui
qui aujourd'hui ont pas de scrupules ils
arrivent à enlever la vie' d'art
aujourd'hui d'un travailleur qui était
en plein travail pour un contrôle
d'identité ou un contrôle de deux je
sais pas ce qu'ils ont pour thème
comment qui ont prétexté le téléphone il
a dit qu'il avait un téléphone un casque
avec après décroché sa plaque
d'immatriculation à l'été passe à
l'élite et ultra visite puisque on a des
photos on a tout ce qu'il faut donc
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui sa place à 6 mars et 1 meur
je sais que des archaïsmes pas que j'en
parle moi ceci n'a mais là je parle de
mon fils cédric joue bien voilà on a tué
cédric joue bien sur le pavé au pied de
la tour eiffel
donc voilà et aujourd'hui on a un gros
problème c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
vidéos
il ya beaucoup de vidéos de l'instant où
ça s'est passé et de la scène voilà
aujourd'hui le ministre a évoqué
effectivement hier la réforme de l'igpn
la police des polices
c'est un début là aussi plus
d'indépendance de cette police des
polices avec peut-être moins d'impunité
du coup je pense parce que la police des
polices aujourd'hui à des polices pour
eux pour régler les problèmes de la
police
donc ça fait un peu ambigu par contre si
vous mettez une police complètement
extérieur un organisme complètement
extérieur pour savoir ce qui se passe
dans la police
peut-être qu'il y aura des meilleurs
contrôles et des meilleurs c'est fait
moi je peux vous donner une situation ma
belle fille quand un pays tel gpn à la
fin elle est temps de rentrer elle a été
entendue deux heures ou une heure ou
deux heures jusque lui et on lui a dit
vous savez vous avez plus de facilité
que nous pour faire des investigations
joué à dix à la femme à qui on vient de
tuer le mari et et ceux qui le disent on
a plus de facilité à faire des
investigations
oui c'est à nous pouvait rentrer dans
les commissariats mais mener nos
enquêtes dire aux gens vous êtes des
menteurs par des montages c'est un gag
sagan du gpn parlant des moyens selon
vous
justement par volonté d' impunité
certaine impunité parce qu'on veut
passer vers la police alors dans le
temps on appelle ça une bavure
maintenant on appelle ça du du racisme
on appelle savez les commandes de des
violences policières
on appelle ça fait avant c'est une
bavure alors c'était le mot et d'efforts
aujourd'hui c'est des violences
policières
les violences policières aujourd'hui
existent elles sont pas faites par tous
les policiers
ça s'est fait de certains on n'en veut
pas toutes les polices de france on n'a
pas de haine contre la police la famille
de shoya tout cas ravi juillet n'a pas
de haine contre la police
moi j'ai de la haine on amène entre ces
quatre individus qui nous ont eu une vie
notre la vie de notre enfant de notes du
père du mari du frère c'est atroce vie
aujourd'hui cinq mois après on est comme
au premier jour
quand le petit qu'à quatre ans le petit
dernier à quatre ans il dit je veux voir
mon papa aussi tiers qui s'ouvrira
compter quand il est temps at on si un
vrai problème aujourd'hui
sari problème tout ça parce que il ya
quatre individus qu'on décidé un beau
jour de faire un contrôle et d'aller au
bout de leurs contrôles sont pas arrêtés
mesrine des screen est déjà enterré
maison pas arrêté non ils ont arrêté un
pauvre qui bossaient voilà un
travailleur qui rame qui travaillait
pour nourrir 5 enfants et travailler et
sa femme
et voilà donc aujourd'hui je peux pas
accepter ça peut pas accepter ça honteux
pas que c'était sa merci christian
souvient en tout cas votre témoignage en
direct sur arte france merci à vous